G1
[Música]
o
Toddy muitos de nós finalmente nos
conscientizamos de que muita coisa na
nossa sociedade precisa ser transformada
precisa mudar de fato não tá bom para
todo mundo não tá bom para todos os
grupos sociais que a gente tem não está
bom para as pessoas negras não está bom
para as pessoas indígenas não está bom
para as mulheres
não está bom para os idosos as pessoas
que tem algum tipo de deficiência física
não está bom para turma LGBT que ia mais
não está bom para as crianças para as
mães enfim nós temos problemas sociais
seríssimos que fazem parte estão
enraizados na história da formação do
nosso país nós temos o racismo nós temos
o sexismo nós temos a fome EA pobreza
nós temos desemprego nós temos a falta
de moradia e enfim diversos elementos
que compõem o tão falado quadro das
desigualdades
Nesse contexto de problemas tão
profundos e difíceis de se solucionar se
eu falar para você em direito à cidade
Pode parecer um pouco estranho na mesma
até porque na nossa percepção a gente
transita pela cidade a gente vai e volta
como quando com quem a gente quer nos
momentos em que a gente quer mas eu acho
que é um momento da gente parar e se
perguntar será que é mesmo assim será
que nós realmente
temos o direito de usufruir das cidades
Será que a gente transita de fato por
todos os espaços que a gente escolher no
momento que a gente escolher da forma
que a gente escolher
é bom direito à cidade é uma expressão
né um conceito que foi cunhado por um
sociólogo francês chamado Henri lefebvre
e 1968 o em que ele é ferro ele vai
definir leduar a La Ville traduzido
direito à cidade da seguinte forma
significa o direito dos cidadãos e dos
grupos que eles constituem sobre as
bases das relações sociais de figurar
sobre todas as redes circuitos de
comunicação de informação e de trocas
bom partindo dessa definição a gente já
começa a ver tem algum problema tem
alguma questão aí que não fica bem
encaixada a gente tem uma sociólogo
holandesa que é uma das maiores
intelectuais da contemporaneidade que
também é referência em estudos
urbanos né do espaço urbano da cidade
das relações dentro da e se chama Saskia
sassen Saskia sassen ela vai dizer o
seguinte numa entrevista que ela deu
alguns anos atrás nós precisamos
desestabilizar
conceitos estáveis bom eu considero essa
fala das aska um convite para que a
gente
começa a refletir sobre coisas que estão
tão naturalizados na nossa sociedade que
a gente nem se dá conta mais de que
aquilo tá ali todos esses problemas
históricos que eu tô falando aqui todo
esse quadro de desigualdade tem muita
coisa que a gente não consegue perceber
caminhando pela cidade de tão acostumado
que estamos e nos deparar com essas
situações
e
o geógrafo Milton Santos que é um baiano
incrível um dos maiores intelectuais do
mundo também
nos seus textos nos seus artigos né mas
famosos ele fala sobre um conceito que
ele também cunhou que é de cidadania
mutilada o Milton Santos ele vai dizer o
seguinte se a gente não vivencie as
cidades de maneira igualitária Justa e
equilibrada e integral nós não podemos
dizer que somos cidadãos ou cidadãos
pois bem
esses problemas acompanham a formação
histórica do nosso país quando a gente
fala na questão racial na questão de
gênero na questão de classes né que ele
aqui visão as vivências dentro da
sociedade a gente também tá falando de
coisas que vão se espelhar que vão ser
encontradas materializados nos Espaços
da cidade então a gente pode concluir
que o nosso espaço urbano ele é o chão
onde as questões sociais vão estar
cravadas desenhadas
arquitetura e urbanismo que são
profissões antigas né saberes
profissionais antigos eles não são
neutros tão pouco são silenciosos eles
são altamente discursivos e se vale de
símbolos que contam histórias Inclusive
a nossa história a história da formação
do nosso país as nossas cidades ela se
formaram já lá no período colonial e
elas se formaram a partir de uma espécie
de transporte do modelo de cidade do
modelo de espaço urbano lá de Portugal
que era fortemente influenciado pelas
civilizações greco-romanas
então a as nossas cidades elas foram
inicialmente pensadas para defesa do
território
e não exatamente para proporcionar um
ambiente favorável à formação da
Cidadania das pessoas que iriam ocupar
aquele aí as fortificações são tipo de
arquitetura um tipo de construção que
marcam bem esse período da nossa
história isso fez com que
alguns elementos que já existiam lá
naquele espaço né de Portugal com forte
influência greco-romana se
transportassem para as cidades ou seja
nós herdamos de lá também um caráter
extremamente
segregacionista e excludente que a gente
pode observar nos Espaços da cidade até
hoje atuante firme e forte muitos
urbanistas definem a cidade com o espaço
fragmentado como um espaço de exclusões
e segregações diversas né partindo do
conceito da Saskia sassen a gente
precisa começar a pensar da seguinte
forma e a gente tem falado da
arquitetura hostil mas na verdade para a
gente conseguir se aprofundar um pouco
mais e entender exatamente o que tem
acontecido nas nossas cidades a gente
tem que dizer estabilizar esse conceito
então se a cidade se arquitetura e
urbanismo são discursivos e apresentam
para gente um histórico de Formação
muito comprometido com a violência que a
gente observa na no nível social então a
gente também tem que dizer que
arquitetura e urbanismo estão sendo
violentos e não exatamente os X não
apenas os X arquitetura que é
responsável pelo projeto de edificações
é prédios casas escolas hospitais e
urbanismo que engloba o planejamento
Urbano as políticas urbanas a
distribuição das idades dos mobiliários
nos Espaços que a gente frequenta
e precisam ter um olhar mais criterioso
para sua participação no quadro de
violência que a gente quer combatendo no
nível social
Oi Valéria Gonzales que é uma das
maiores intelectuais
sobretudo do feminismo negro das
Relações raciais no país também
reconhecido internacionalmente no seu
livro lugar de negro que ela publicou
por volta da do começo da década de 80
em parceria com o sociólogo Chamado
Carlos Raça é um bug ela vai dizer né na
verdade ela vai alertar para a divisão
racial do Espaço das cidades a lélia
Gonzalez ela vai ser categórico em dizer
que existe nas cidades o lugar do branco
e o lugar do negro o lugar do branco é
um lugar do Bem Viver é o lugar do
conforto é o lugar da livre expressão e
vivência o lugar do negro é o lugar da
subalternidade é o lugar da precariedade
é o lugar da escassez e da violência
escancarada
bom então o problema social que nós
temos chamado racismo ele também vai
definir como a cidade se comporta mas
não só nós temos também a questão de
gênero que também influencia na dinâmica
das cidades a jurista e urbanista A
Betânia alfonsin no seu artigo cidade
para todas cidade para todos vai dizer
vai nos alertar Aqui as nossas cidades
estão muito vinculadas ao modelo
greco-romano sobretudo da Grécia onde
você tinha apólices que eram espaço
público onde se discutia política e se
tomava as principais decisões que
aconteceriam naquele espaço nesse lugar
só os homens podiam estar ali só os
homens podiam participar da vida pública
para as mulheres era destinado o
ambiente doméstico ou Oikos
lugar também onde ficavam os escravos e
os Animais Então a partir daí a gente
consegue Me dê o caráter
absolutamente excludente que vem também
pela vertente pelo pensamento da questão
de gênero o corpo da mulher é um corpo
que conceitualmente
existe para ocupar os espaços domésticos
ainda que a gente transite pela cidade
fazendo uma série de coisas a mulher têm
alcançado e conquistar o seu espaço nós
no espaço público nosso corpo também é
visto como um corpo público haja Vista a
quantidade de assédios né a quantidade
de estupros a quantidade de violências
psicológicas que a gente passa no nosso
trajeto pelas cidades muitas vezes a
gente tem que mudar percursos a gente
tem que alterar as nossas horários de
trânsito pelas cidades porque a gente
precisa pensar primeiramente na nossa
segurança pois bem não é só a questão de
raça E de gênero que influencia as
dinâmicas EA distribuição das cidades e
também tem um forte caráter de
hierarquiza São por classe econômica
isso também vai ser traduzir os nossos
Espaços das cidades nós temos por
exemplo
um grande número de carros ocupando um
espaço que é majoritariamente para as
pessoas que deveria ser majoritariamente
para pessoas os carros na cidade ocupam
mais espaço do que as pessoas né isso
principalmente porque o carro virou ao
longo da história um símbolo né de
status social para Além da questão do
carro que tem sido discutido aí pelas
pessoas que fazem uma militância do
cicloativismo da mobilidade a pé a gente
vai ter também uma outra questão que é
bem grave que a questão Habitacional né
A questão Habitacional ou déficit
Habitacional nosso país manda leva
muitas pessoas a morar nas favelas nas
encostas nas habitações irregulares
insalubres
é muito isso presente nesse período de
pandemia o quanto isso é importante
desse discutido agora tem um extremo da
questão Habitacional não resolvida do
nosso país que é a questão das pessoas
que vivem em situação de rua
é só em São Paulo nós temos cerca de 30
mil pessoas que vivem nessa condição
E essas pessoas elas acabam carregando
um estigma um conjunto de preconceitos e
estereótipos que vai fazer com que essas
pessoas sofreram muitos danos e é daí
que a gente vem discutindo a questão da
arquitetura hostil por exemplo né a
gente observou no último semestre
agora desceram de 2021 um caso que tomou
proporções e midiáticas né que durante a
noite no viaduto de grande movimentação
foi instalado uns paralelepípedos uns os
obstáculos pontiagudos para impedir que
essas pessoas em situação de rua
ocupassem esse lugar para pernoitar ou
enfim para se abrigar da chuva das
intempéries
climáticas e tudo mais isso é uma grande
violência né esse não foi o não é o
único exemplo que a gente encontra nas a
net ge exclusão de segregação de repulsa
as pessoas em condição em situação de
rua ajustar tem outros exemplos né que a
gente pode observar de Barreiras físicas
que se colocam nos Espaços
descaradamente para não permitir que
essas pessoas possam permanecer ali
então a gente vê bancos de Praças por
exemplo com barreiras para que a pessoa
não possa deitar exticao seu corpo
a gente observa taxas que elementos
pontiagudos que também não permitem que
uma pessoa em situação de rua sente ali
para descansar para comer a sua refeição
ou para enfim qualquer finalidade as
pessoas em situação de rua oitenta por
cento delas são pessoas negras
essa condição de não ter onde morar ou
demorar nos espaços de favela de
Periferia por exemplo não é a condição
casual isso é resultado dos nossos
processos históricos a Eugenia definiu
também os espaços da cidade a maneira
como se distribuem
da mesma forma nós tivemos políticas
fundiárias
extremamente segregacionistas que
favoreceram apenas um grupo social desde
as capitanias hereditárias passando pela
lei de terras de 1850 que vai
transformar a terra em mercadoria E aí
vai dificultar ainda mais o acesso para
pessoas indígenas as pessoas negras
mulheres né então a questão da pessoa em
situação de rua ela é um resultante
desses processos históricos agora tem um
outro elemento também nas cidades que
vai definir muita coisa que é a questão
do apagamento
eu tive caminhando pela cidade de
Blumenau E aí se observa uma forte
influência alemã para todo lado que a
gente olha imagina se a gente tira essa
influência alemã as informações
arquitetônicas e de distribuição do
espaço que nos remetem a memória da
ocupação alemã na cidade o que que
aconteceria com essas pessoas elas não
se ela se sentiriam deslocados do seu
lugar ela se sentiram descoladas da sua
história mas a gente pode dizer que nas
cidades a gente não consegue ver a
presença das pessoas negras das pessoas
indígenas das mulheres que são pessoas
que também trabalharam ativamente para a
construção
literalmente braçal dos espaços das
cidades em São Paulo por exemplo
recentemente foi resgatada a história do
primeiro arquiteto negro O thebas que
foi um grande Construtor que foi
responsável por muitas obras ali de
médio e grande porte na São Paulo do
século 18 a gente tem também o bairro da
Liberdade que atualmente se chama
Liberdade Japão nós sabemos que existe
no bairro uma forte e da Cultura
nipônica né dos Imigrantes Japoneses mas
aquele bairro começou com uma expressiva
população negra e que agora isso é
apagado Esse é suprimido da história
tirar das cidades a forma a informação
de quem a construiu provoca nas pessoas
um sentimento de não pertencimento a
impressão que nós temos é que a cidade é
apenas e exclusivamente dos homens dos
homens brancos porque só o nome deles os
monumentos enfim os símbolos presentes
ali
só o nome deles constam só o nome de um
grupo social a gente não tem mulheres
numerando Praça a gente não tem pessoas
negras
informações afro informações indígenas
de marcando que aquele espaço também nos
pertence né isso afeta de muitas formas
então quando a gente tá com falando na
questão do direito à cidade a gente tá a
discussão de como a nossa formação
física o nosso espaço de convivência
física precisa ser criteriosamente
avaliado porque senão todo e qualquer
política que se pretenda erradicar as
desigualdades sociais elas não vão se
resolver efetivamente as idades elas
foram construídas por esses processos
históricos e elas espelham tudo isso
seria muito bacana inclusive para nossa
saúde mental que as nossas cidades
fossem
inclusivas fossem empáticos
convidativas para a formação de uma
sociabilidade
mas afetiva né seria muito legal que a
gente conseguisse olhar para uma cidade
Justa e igualitária isso não tem
acontecido
e a essa conversa de direito à cidade
ela é fundamental porque é a partir daí
que a gente vai conseguir ter uma
leitura crítica da formação histórica
tanto social quanto a urbana EA partir
daí a gente vai conseguir inclusive
propor mudanças e transformações
conjuntas entre o que se passa na
sociedade e o que a sociedade está
esperando para os espaços físicos que
nós ocupamos
bom então buscar transformações sociais
passa invariavelmente pela leitura do
nosso território e pela solução dos
problemas históricos que se acumularam
diante deles
muito obrigada ó